hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
candy's 3 now we may have a new opponent
in the next night but we still have to
explore more here hello I dressed how
you do it hey cat I have bad news I
think the cat is lurking around it you
have to be extra careful miss the
monster cat is very sweet he'll probably
try to get you from the ground each end
of your bed is up and as you keep here
either very left to the very right side
flashlight thing will work on it too so
remember to be extra sharp tonight well
that sounds bad on all counts right but
all my toys
good lad your organ mail dresser where I
put all my dresses very organized
alright so what I got to do is I got to
go into the dreamscape when the shadow
cat is here your time in the darkness
will be short do not waste your time for
when it runs out you'll find you
I dunno knows that means there's nothing
on the bed I don't know that mean oh oh
that's a slow tick I think I'm good the
only path is not always the right path
uh East from this rock alright I travel
Hey
alrighty then whoa alrighty then yeah
didn't expect you to be there douche
nozzle so just go deal with the cat I
thought there was gonna be a new thing
that happened to me what screw you then
I'm not gonna go that way first I'm
gonna go this way and then
well [ __ ] okay alright we're good I
guess I don't know hello part of a
newspaper article read it sure the
rotten cat theater the perfect place for
entertainment for children of all ages
we have a show every one of the five
weekdays
well great what does that mean for me
I'm in a dream why do I remember
newspaper ads in a dream what kind of
game huh so I gotta explore you I'll be
right back nope sorry
with my eyeballs okay so I gotta go
north I'm gonna whip thee I'm crossing
the barrier no one can stop me please
don't stop me don't stop me thank you I
was almost there ride in er whoa the
monsters will knock on the doors when
they become angry but they only knock on
one of the doors that they're not act
monsters always try to fool you do they
now there's nothing on the back well
that's an interesting note ah hello part
of a newspaper sure enjoy the shows
enjoy the company we even have three
arcade machines you can enjoy while you
wait alrighty then
ah it seems decrepid why am I here am I
going I don't know where I've come from
or where I've been no okay I know that's
ah that's the eastern way to the the
Frick dickin what Yuma call it yeah The
Rock the wing of the rocker Johnson
all right path this way
yep I got it okay part of a newspaper
let's read everyone will have fun even
the adults we have an area for adults to
chat while enjoying free coffee
what does that mean I don't know no no
I've been escaping from you yeah you
think you're so evil now we'll look how
evil I am as a little girl roll okay
hello hey run arcade game three one four
twine to okay I don't know maybe I can
make like the time run out or something
you don't know which way I'm coming from
Google Oh miss me I just got back onto
the normal Road I guess you don't know
which way I'm coming from where did I
come from where to go where to come from
kanojo I've ever duck oh it's you I
don't mind if you don't remember me we
used to play when you were very very
little I was one of your first toys but
that was many years ago I probably don't
matter anymore
you should move along in your life if
you have anything to say say it now I I
mean hello I guess I I don't I don't
know what to say exactly I don't know
but I've got a technique to avoid the
rat a little bit at least throw them off
my trail let's see does that
even with a few do comedy Beauchamp Nemo
shot him okay a vivo shouting where's
the other goddamn thing can't touch me
the only other thing to do that I can
think of would be to let the time run
out I don't know if that's gonna mean
but might as well give it a go to see in
a few minutes all right here we go
whatever this is gonna do 10 9 8 7 6 5 4
3 2 1 yeah all right okay all right so I
can't seem to find anything else and I
don't want to spend forever just
wandering in the darkness so I've got
one half of the arcade game and I found
a toy I don't know what else to do go to
sleep
yeah man I really need to I guess I
could go back but without a map I'm
gonna be kind of lost so just gotta do
what I can against the monster cat now
he likes to look at the foots in my bed
so where you be kitty cat will you be so
I got a look at the extreme left ah
goodbye hey I heard that I forgot about
my music I can't sleep without my mute
eye okay all right that was really
creepy will you be doing that gonna be
hard for me to tell my nightmare stories
if you're looking at the foot of a bed
maybe you're under my bed too oh I saw
that saw that hmm
man it's really creepy because if you
just glance over them it doesn't count
you got to actually spot them and see
these eyes staring at you from the
darkness well boy ah
Frick where'd you go I see you in there
hey I heard that too
you made a noisy new boy okay so you
guys apparently want more nightmare
stories woman why I got a lot of them so
Oh heard that oh boy hi okay alright
anyway so why do I feel with two of them
so a lot of my nightmares mostly
happened when I was a kid they were very
um ah I don't know what that was
well that well it's what's the Foom yeah
anyway a lot of my nightmares they
happen when the the dream starts out
normal and fun and and free but oh [ __ ]
as a kid I don't know I'm super nervous
inside but as kid I would have a lot of
lucid dreams like a lot of lucid dreams
I used to be able to lucid dream pretty
much whenever I wanted to this
frequently no you're not going to knock
there huh
I gotcha the knocks are a lie so I would
be able to lucid dream I haven't been
able to have a lucid dream in a long
time until just recently like a few
months ago but when I was a kid I was
able to just fly around and obey oh boy
oh boy oh boy
[ __ ] I didn't expect you to be in the
middle - okay that's gonna end up with
you under my bed isn't it yeah God how
much light do you need [ __ ] vitamin D
deficient [ __ ] ah
[Music]
friend here you friend the cat there
yeah yes he is there I look at him
please oh god oh god oh god where'd he
go don't scare me don't you sneak on me
by the immortal words of my mom in the
face of anything Fred delicious don't
sneak on me goddamned I really can't
[ __ ] focus on anything okay so lucid
dream me kid nightmare screams it
happened a lot so
it usually started out very fine where I
was able to control but as time went on
I would just like the the nightmares
would devolve or the dreams would
devolve into nightmares [ __ ] and I
just wouldn't be able to control them
anymore like it was the weirdest
sensation to have a lucid dream
and then slowly have control ripped from
my hands like I was in a world where I
was able to fly and do whatever I wanted
it was raining in the front yard it was
sunshine in the backyard you know that
sort of thing
and I think like as a kid like you're
able to do that just because your world
is much smaller therefore your dreams
don't have as much you know stuff to
work with so it's easier to when you
know your world very well especially if
you just like grew up in the same house
or you know you don't go to school yet
or something like that or you go to like
a very small school which I did when I
was growing up it's easier to know
you're dreaming because you'll be able
to tell the differences but this didn't
happen whenever I whenever these lucid
dreams start turning into nightmares
because I would just be in my backyard
and I would be playing around with my
brother or something or in the dream of
course I'd be playing around with my
brother and then like I was able to
control it and you know for some reason
I didn't recognize that my brother
wasn't also dreaming with me you know he
well obviously was in there but in the
dream I thought he was and then I would
turn around and he'd be gone hi okay
hello 90 hidey-hidey-ho how are you
doing
under there all right we can deal with
this music oh stop when you pop out
Rikyu we said took care of the cat first
so that's an important lesson to learn
if the cats there you got to take care
of the cat first yeah that's good that's
real good okay
so my brother would just be gone and
then I would be in the backyard alone
and then suddenly like I knew I was
dreaming but I couldn't control it
anymore like tried to fly couldn't do it
ooh break a dick so it didn't really
like end anywhere cataclysmic it's not
like vines started growing out of the
ground or anything like that it was just
like I I just had this overwhelming
sense of dread when I was in there
because like my brother was gone and
like he like this guy got a little
darker and then everything just started
getting a little darker and so I I went
the only place that I thought it could
be and I went into the woods like
because we had this Creek by our house
that we'd always go and play together
and just me and my brother and it was
just it was just always good to go back
there so I just assumed he went back
there but then when I stepped like into
the boundary into the forest like I
started to forget that I was lucid
dreaming like I forgot it was the
weirdest thing when I woke up and
realized it but I forgot that I was in
control and then control was completely
ripped from me and I was just wandering
endlessly in the creek like over and
over and over again endlessly everywhere
I went looking for my brother calling
out for him crying like I was just
completely distraught that my brother
was gone because it's like this
transition of mind where you believe the
dream is a dream and then suddenly the
dream is real and it was just I was
terrifying I woke up from then I had to
go like check on my brother to make sure
he was still there not outside lost in
the woods god
but there are there is like tons of
occurrences like that where that was
just the earliest example that I could
think of it where I was able to lucid
dream as a kid and then control is gone
and so like only it was only like until
about a year later that my lucid dreams
just stopped in general I wasn't able to
I wasn't able to I heard that yeah think
you can trick me you cannot you cannot
you can add yeah so I hadn't been able
to lucid dream for a long time just like
I can only remember once or twice in
like teenage years and then once just
recently okay we got a knock at that is
actually a thing or is it just a fakie
thing you think I'm gonna win though
which is good like I don't know how many
years guys out there can lose a dream ah
don't screw this up for me because I
haven't oh no don't do that to me oh you
[ __ ] dare
I can't yeah I guess dead [ __ ] is going
on with my player stop that stop okay so
they interrupted it or something or it
got caught up and nothing yeah I don't
like that [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
yeah that's right oh yeah you go away
okay
okay all right Jesus stressful I don't
know why having a cat in the room
there's an make me any happier Oh what
is that
are we going back oh we're back all
right now what have you got for me let's
go to other horrible months yes - these
are waiting for me here oh hey you again
my daddy said the puppeteers puppet is a
double puppet means it's both a string
puppet and event [ __ ] a little wisp
puppet do you know not how to say
Ventrella go hey hello there kid I'm the
puppeteer normally my friend Benny is
with me but he's resting right now maybe
I'll get to meet him after today's show
if you want to I don't know I don't know
if I want to seems like a bad idea all
around there's everything about this
nightmare world hi sweetie
have you met the puppeteer he's here
early today okay if you say so I don't
know how you keep bringing me here and
they only cause me nightmares
I met the puppeteer he's my friend now I
even made a drawing for him he really
liked it now I've drawn a drawing for
the cat and the puppeteer now I just
need the rat it's my friend - okay
that's how friendship works I already
beat my old high score in all the games
not like I could ever use those skills
for anything useful I wonder if you
could get paid for playing games in the
future huh this kid seems to have a a
grasp on things in life but no
absolutely not oh hey my little pal
early for the show
I'll burn out around I'm Zeke one of
them's like they know don't be sad
because it won't last
tell me if you change your mind around
how about yes
you know you hide again then I'll count
all righty then
goody goody gumdrops I doubt you're
gonna tell me now you're not gonna tell
me anything new are you your answer no
can I have in the girls room about the
table right under my dad dad protect me
there's a crazy right oh okay got you
got you again I don't know if there's
any way to win that I doubt it anyway
all right
well anyway that's it for that night now
it's too easy
I didn't even lose on that night so I'm
going to continue on to the 4th and see
if I can dive deeper into the mystery
here got to be more sublime I starting
from up there
why did I start from up there you're
remembering more and more look at your
rump you barely remembered it before I
have a feeling that you'll be able to
get rid of those the nightmares soon
just keep fighting it then I'm sure
you'll beat them for good
alrighty mile drawing table all right
then I'm gonna go up and see what the
hell is going on in Knight Maryland like
maybe the way nightmare land instructs
no it's not dream trees grow when one
becomes familiar with the unfamiliar let
them serve as guides to let you know
where you are
ok there's nothing on the back alright
dream tree if that's your real name
uh-huh dream tree that doesn't really
help me yeah all right then yeah that's
how it's gonna be huh
oh you guys mean business
[Music]
damn it I can't get anywhere that's died
I just can't get anywhere not letting me
Wow
yeah there ain't no getting away from
that yeah I can't go anywhere I don't
know why but I just can't go anywhere
I don't know what to do I've gone every
single direction I possibly can
I don't know what it wants see any other
road man that sucks okay I guess I can't
go anywhere it's super weird why every
other night I've been able to go
everywhere but the rat is just
absolutely breathing down my neck I
wonder if that's a metaphor for what's
gonna happen in this night I don't know
I don't know maybe I don't think I have
another nightmare story to tell you
other than just I have a lot of
nightmares so how do we just get through
this one because I'm probably going to
need to concentrate
alright you [ __ ] let's see what
you're made of turns out they're made of
sharp claws and sharp teeth and yes and
a lot of it a whole lot of it oh we got
who's be snips a balloon
alright is it just the two you just to
do it's just to you so come on what you
think you can do to me what you think
you can do okay
I heard that before I saw yeah easy did
you copy that me
don't send shivers down my spine
ah no uh-uh
where you ah [ __ ] you think he said you
would not knock when you'd need to cause
his bathroom be oil energy how could you
be so busy damn it hot damn damn
you've got damn damn this Swan Co you
run off to be good Ratan [ __ ] up and die
yeah hey huh what's that hey back off a
little bit more than that oh you know
okay bye [ __ ] no oh hey how's it go
on what the hell's the knock Enochs
there you getting angry is that that
whole deal I think that's what that
might appear on [ __ ] fire fire [ __ ]
up yeah and yeah
yeah [ __ ] goddamn it not about bats
okay oh my god hey honey I think
encounter hi
Oh God look at the Gandhi again hi what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] God can you
not be broken dick please [ __ ] trying
to make me die from goddamn turn right
by whoa where why what [ __ ] you what I
thought the knocks came from the
opposite that's what I was instructed I
heard that bad
[ __ ] oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no hello where hi oh hi oh god damn
it
what do we die die [ __ ] stop go go go
go down go down go down go down gonna
Jesus Christmas uh this time I got a man
[ __ ] you I think they're on the same
goddamn side I think that cat oh hi cat
that cat that cat that one right there
it must uh must get a little uh you know
excited a little more mustard in its
step whenever it uh knows the rats about
oh it knows what the rats about ah with
me hey we're doing with my dang we're
doing where's my ping oh no you should
car likes to steal my recorder okay
anyway that's all the time they got this
one I gave a few tries at night for I'll
pick it up later so thank you everybody
so much for watching hope you're
enjoying this that makes a little more
difficult but there is breathing it's
just hard for me to hear it when the
music's playing
I got a crunch Cup play with it louder
and blast my eardrums out when they
scare me but either way I'll figure that
out thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]